foreign
[Music]
I hope all of you having great Google
Cloud next 2023 thank you so much for
taking the time from your busy day and
spending it with us
over the next 45 minutes we're going to
be talking about postgres
I'm going to kick it off by saying that
I love postgres and the fact that all of
you are here today means I think all of
you love postgres as well is that right
Make Some Noise if you love postgres all
right awesome I need it
so postgres is one of the most popular
open source relational databases in the
world
and for good reason postgres has been in
active development now for over 35 years
and it all started at the University of
California and Berkeley not far away
from here right and because of 35 years
of active development what we have is an
open source database that is robust
an open source database that scales
really well
and open source database that is
extensible which means you can easily
customize it for the use case that you
have in mind and last but not least an
open source database that is highly
conformant with the ANSI SQL standards
hundreds and hundreds of people around
the world have contributed to make
postgres what it is today
and all around the world just like how
we've come together here today to talk
about postgres there are hundreds of
events and user groups but people who
like postgres come together brainstorm
and learn from each other so I'm going
to take a moment to thank the poseless
community for making this open source
database available for us
so this is the agenda for the next 45
minutes we're going to do introductions
I'll introduce the speakers for today we
will then do an introduction of cloud
SQL and Cloud SQL for postgres
we will then talk about some of the
Innovations we recently made in Cloud
SQL specifically around availability and
performance two vectors that are very
important if you want to run Mission
critical workloads on postgres
we'll deep dive into them and we'll talk
to you about how we made these
Innovations possible
and like I said earlier postgres is
highly extensible which means that you
can modify it quickly to meet the use
cases that are important for you one
such use case that is very which is of
high interest right now is Gen AI so
we'll talk about Ai and ML and we'll
deep dive into how you can use postgres
for building gen AI applications
that will bring to Cloud SQL for
postgres users on stage they will talk
to you about how they've deployed Cloud
SQL for postgres at scale what lessons
they've learned from that and best
practices that they'll share with you
we'll follow that with q a so there's a
mic over here if you have any questions
please come up to the mic and ask those
questions so that everybody can hear the
question of course Jana and I will be
here after the session as well to answer
any questions that you might have
so my name is Bala narasimhan I'm a
group product manager for cloud SQL I'm
joined on stage by Jana van goon Jana is
engineering director for cloud SQL we
will be joined on stage by with Richard
Helms Richard is a manager for database
engineering at sales Loft and also Stacy
Knapps Stacy is an engineering manager
for SRE at pen entertainment
so let's start off by a quick
introduction to Cloud SQL and Cloud SQL
for postgres so what is cloud SQL Cloud
SQL is a managed service for relational
databases Cloud SQL is a tried and
tested service
upwards of 95 percent of all gcp gcp's
top 100 users use cloud SQL today
Cloud SQL supports three relational
database engines postgres MySQL and SQL
server and we aspire to give you full
compatibility with these three engines
and what I mean by that is if you have
an application that runs today and is
leveraging one of those three engines
you should be able to move that
application to Cloud SQL as is and it
will just work
Cloud SQL is also fully managed and
Enterprise ready what that basically
means is with a few clicks or with an
API call you are able to provision a
cloud SQL instance you no longer have to
worry about provisioning infrastructure
patching software setting up workflows
for availability data protection
Disaster Recovery Etc because we take
care of all of that for you we take care
of the mundane so that you can focus on
what matters which is building
applications
we bring Google's best practices around
security for you
and last but not least we aspire to be
developer friendly what we mean by that
is if there's a developer who wants to
build a new application we want them to
be comfortable using Cloud SQL to that
end we Embrace infrastructure as code we
have full terraform support we have KCC
support we have a powerful API that you
can use and every workflow that you can
do through the console you can do
through the API as well we also bring
you developer-centric observability via
query insights and system insights it
provides you a rich set of traces logs
and metrics so that you can troubleshoot
your instance quite easily
Cloud SQL for postgres is postgres as a
managed service it is open source
postgres we provide you open source
postgres as a managed service this means
that you are able to leverage all the
Innovation that the community is
building for you
and there's no concerns around using
proprietary software because this is
open source postgres because it is a
managed service like I said earlier we
take care of the mundane for you you
don't have to provision infrastructure
you don't need to patch software and you
don't need to set up complicated
workflows for things like availability
and data protection we take care of all
of that for you you can spin up an
instance in a few minutes and you can
focus on building new applications
and Cloud signal postgres is innovating
rapidly on the right hand side of the
slide here you're seeing few of the
innovations that we've had recently the
first is PG Vector support which allows
you to build gen AI applications and as
I said earlier we'll be deep diving into
that some other things is support for up
to almost 200 flags and 50 plus
extensions on the security front the
support for IIM based authentication and
strong password policies for local
username passwords more recently we
launched pi3r support for unavailable
instances you're able to now do point in
time recovery even when an instance is
down which reduces the RPO and RPO
considerably
but we understand that a database is
just one piece of the puzzle as you're
looking to build an application you want
an entire ecosystem around the database
you want solutions for migrations you
want solutions for bi and analytics you
want solutions for observability and
security and so be really excited to
announce Google cloud ready Cloud SQL
Partners today so this is a set of tools
that we have certified through a due
diligence process to make sure that
these tools work really well with Cloud
SQL right so you have the peace of mind
that if you want to use one of those
tools they have gone through a rigorous
technical evaluation process and it
works really well with Cloud SQL
all right so now I'm going to spend some
time talking about the Innovations
around availability and performance that
we recently announced for cloud SQL
specifically I'm going to talk about the
Enterprise Plus Edition for postgres
as customers are bringing their
applications to the cloud they keep
asking us for three things when they're
talking about their most Mission
critical applications the first is
higher performance the second is higher
availability and the third is better
data protection and it goes along these
three vectors that we innovated when we
announced the Enterprise Plus Edition
for postgres
so two things to call out here for the
Enterprise Plus the first is improve
performance and scale out of the box and
the other is business continuity the
improvements in business continuity so
let's Deep dive into that let's talk
about how we were able to deliver better
performance and scale out of the box and
what the better business continuity is
so as far as the Enterprise Plus Edition
goes there's two things that we've done
firstly we have optimized Hardware that
we're using to provision these Cloud SQL
instances and secondly because we run a
very large Fleet of postgres we
understand how best to optimize the
deployment of that postgres software to
best Leverage The Power of the hardware
on which it's running and it's a
combination of those two things that
allows the Enterprise Plus Edition to
have better performance out of the box
and we've seen up to a 2X Improvement in
right throughput for Enterprise spread
plus Edition compared to the Enterprise
Edition so what are the specific
Hardware optimizations we are talking
about here right the first is that we're
leveraging the N family of machines
types right so we're using the N family
machine types when you provision
Enterprise Plus instance you're getting
an N family machine type the second is a
higher core to memory ratio compared to
the Enterprise Edition where that ratio
is one is to 6 and a half in Enterprise
Plus that ratio is one is to eight which
means that for the same number of cores
you're getting more RAM which in turn
means that you're able to store more of
the working set of your database in
memory which results in better
performance
we also are supporting larger instant
shapes with Enterprise plus we're
supporting up to 128 cores and 864 gigs
of RAM for a postgres instance that's
Enterprise Plus this is in contrast to
the Enterprise Edition where we support
96 cores and 624 gigs of RAM so it's a
combination of all of these Hardware
improvements that are allowing us to
give you better performance and as I
mentioned earlier because we have the
learnings from running a very large
Fleet of postgres instances we also know
how best to deploy that postgres
software in a way that will leverage
these Hardware improvements and it's a
combination of those two things that's
resulting in the improved performance
and in our internal benchmarking we have
seen up to a 2X Improvement in right
throughput for Enterprise Plus compared
to the Enterprise Edition
so what are the Innovations we've made
on the business continuity front the
first is that we announced a four nines
SLA for Enterprise Plus
this is in contrast the Enterprise
Edition which is a three and a half
nines SLA
in addition to that Enterprise Plus has
maintenance included in that SLA meaning
the four nines SLA is inclusive of
Maintenance downtime
whereas in the Enterprise Edition the
three and a half nines SLA has a
maintenance curve out
the second thing is that we have reduced
the amount of time uh downtime
associated with maintenance we call it
near zero downtime maintenance because
that's exactly what it is the downtime
associated with maintenance for
Enterprise Plus additions is close to
zero I have a demo that I can show you
will actually show you a postgres
instance that is undergoing maintenance
and you'll see the downtime associated
with that
and last but not least we're announcing
35 days of point in time recovery for
Enterprise Plus instances we have a
number of customers who run in highly
regulated environments where they need
to be able to
restore an instance for up to 35 days
from a particular point in time and so
we are supporting 35 days of pitr this
is in contrast to Enterprise Edition
where we support seven days of pitr
so just to summarize the Enterprise Plus
Edition has Innovations on three fronts
there's improved performance out of the
box there's improved availability
because of the increased SLA and because
of the fact that maintenance is now less
than 10 seconds downtime and the third
is data protection where we're
supporting 35 days of pitr for
Enterprise Plus instances
and with that I'm going to jump into the
demo so before I kick this demo off and
I hope the demo Gods will support me
here what we're going to let me give you
a summary of what I'm going to show you
I have a postgres instance running 15.2
postgres version 15.2 it's an Enterprise
Plus instance it's a production instance
which means that it's set up with aha
enabled what we're going to do then is
we have a client that's going to connect
to that postgres instance and this
client is going to query for a timestamp
from this postgres database in a loop so
you'll see a timestamp being published
continuously in a terminal on the right
and then we are going to kick off
maintenance on the Enterprise Plus
instance
now as some of you may know we support
what's called self-service maintenance
for cloud SQL
in that mode we give you the patches and
you are able to do maintenance on your
postgres instance as and when you choose
so you have the flexibility for in terms
of taking maintenance when we do it for
you or if you want further control on
that we support self-service maintenance
whereby you can maintain your instance
as and when we choose right and so what
I'm going to do is I'm going to kick off
self-service maintenance on this
instance there's a patch available I'm
going to install that patch and when
that maintenance is happening you're
going to see the client uh going through
some disruption right because the
maintenance is happening it's going to
result in some downtime
you will see two seconds of hard down
time on that instance and you'll see
about five seconds or so five or six
seconds if brownout meaning that you
know pretty much most connections are
going through but there's a little bit
of disruption right overall the downtime
is going to be less than 10 seconds with
a hard downtime of just two seconds
all right so let me keep this off
all right
let's see how this goes
all right just to just to orient you
here on the left hand side is the cloud
SQL console that's the production uh
postgres instance as you can see where
it's highlighted in green it suppose
this 15 instance on the right hand side
is a client that is going to connect to
this database
Enterprise Plus
highly available
thank you
and I'm going to show you the script now
as you can tell this script I'm going to
pause this video for a second so you can
take a look at what the script is doing
as you can see it's running in a loop
and it's querying the database for a
timestamp
all right and so when I when I'm going
to run this script now
there you go
as you can see it's publishing a
timestamp in a loop
and now take a pause this for a minute
you're seeing that there's a patch
available
right there's a patch available and I'm
going to do self-service maintenance and
I'm going to install this patch on this
postgres 15 instance
yeah
maintenance has started
you're seeing the initial disruption
there that's the hard downtime that
you're seeing the application has come
back up
right you're seeing that disruption
there the application has come back up
and it's connecting to the database and
it's getting the timestamp back you're
seeing the intermittent
uh connection loss there
oops what happened
okay
sorry about that
I'm going to fast forward that was the
most interesting part
yeah so I'm going to pause this again so
you're seeing downtime started over here
where the red arrow is and downtime
ended when the the hard down time ended
in the first Green Arrow so that's two
seconds of hard down time during
maintenance just two
okay and then you're seeing the
intermittent
connections are coming through once in a
while there's a connection that drops
about seven seconds of that
so this is in contrast By the way to the
maintenance that you would have
experienced in Enterprise Edition of
postgres where the average downtime is
less than 30 seconds so this is a 2X
Improvement in downtime in Enterprise
Plus Edition compared to Enterprise
right so for your most business critical
applications this is a very big deal and
something you should take a look at
and definitely try Cloud SQL Enterprise
Plus
all right and with that we're going to
transition to Ai and ML and as I said
earlier uh postgres is highly extensible
and a lot of our users want to build gen
AI applications on cloud SQL of postgres
and we heard that feedback and we've
introduced support for what's called PG
Vector in Cloud SQL for postgres and we
have a number of customers building
these applications Jana is going to talk
about the technology itself and how you
can go about building those applications
using Cloud SQL composers
awesome thanks Bala yeah I think in
addition to all the really exciting
things in Enterprise plus there's also
some really new kind of application
Level exciting features regarding Ai and
ml in postgres itself
so first I'll ask a question who knows
what a vector is
maybe raise your hand
I know you know maybe four or five
months ago not none of us had really
heard of it but now it's something
that's really taking the application you
know World by storm
so the vector really is in sort of
simple terms is you know life is full of
complex objects we may speak many
languages there are images there are
videos and a vector maps all of these
into just an array of numbers and you
can think about that or number if you
will as being a spot in a
multi-dimensional space
uh so you think why is any of this
important now you can take sentences
like a boy is running and map that into
a space and the boy is walking
you can even take the postgres elephant
image and map that into that space as
well I think that might be quite far
away from the boy walking or running
um but the really really cool thing
about these vectors and using you know a
model to create the vectors
is that the things that are semantically
closer right so a boy doing activities
they're actually closer in this Vector
space and things that are further away
like maybe an adult running
will actually be further away so let's
say you know you're writing stories
about children you can actually do a
search over all this data and find you
know for example book recommendations
about you know children's activities and
it's a it's a very very powerful tool if
you want to add like rich and smart
experiences into your application
the other thing is that's that's all
good but why is this relevant to
databases well it turns out databases
are excellent at storing data numerical
data for sure in tables building indices
over those and then finding what you
need really fast and so it's a perfect
fit to enable this kind of new data type
and new use case within the database
itself
so the other thing digging a little bit
into how this might actually play out in
an application
if we take a retail example
so let's say you had a data catalog in
your database maybe you have some other
details about you know your policies and
how to shop in your store
you take all this data and essentially
run it through an embeddings model that
creates the vectors that we just talked
about
and then these are stored back in the
database
and that can be done offline it can be
refreshed periodically
so now a user will come around and
there's you know application running
and they ask maybe some questions like
what's the return policy or hey you know
I'm searching for let's say an outfit to
wear to a talk can you show me you know
similar things or maybe appropriate
clothing
this these kinds of semantic questions
are generally very hard to you know
answer but this this Vector grouping
makes this all possible
and so basically the the text question
that they have will be converted by an
llm
and basically you know then can be
queried to find similar types of objects
from the data you know from the database
after that it can be passed back into an
llm so there's an integration here
between databases and sort of the
modeling the pre-trained models in AI
and then pass back up to the user
and you know so then the experience
becomes a lot better
so as Bala mentioned there is now a
community extension called PG vector
that will enable all of these Vector
operations for you so it supports a
vector data type but supports a number
of indices so that you can easily
retrieve similar results
and the other part is why is this
important why is this exciting
again having it all in your database is
a really powerful thing it means that
any of your operational concerns already
taken care of
as Paula mentioned you know all these
mundane but very important things around
managing your database making sure it's
available
applying you know security and other
policies to it those are already all
taken care of in your Cloud SQL database
and so this is a very you know one click
easy method installing the extension
to add a whole set of new capabilities
to your application and have all of your
application developers use a database in
a stack that they already know and love
and so this is again we think having it
in database is really kind of a game
changer and I should say the PG Vector
extension is available in Cloud SQL for
postgres as well as lodb for postgres so
all of our postgres interfaces will have
this
and we already have customers using this
this is a quote from a retail customer
called find.com
and they said that by using this
extension they've really been able to
vastly enrich their retail experience
give their users a lot more customizable
you know content and answers
and they all did this with the database
they know so it was really easy for
their application developers to just
turn this on
and I will say this I think if you
didn't know what the vector or gen III
was before Google next please sign up
for many different sessions that we have
on it
so I would say enough about you know
we've given you a lot of information
about all of the cool things that we've
shipped and everything that's new within
Cloud SQL for postgres we'd like to now
actually bring some real customers real
users up onto the stage and here you
know from people from the horse's mouth
what their experience is
so please welcome
Richard and Stacy
[Applause]
cool
so to start off
um I will have them both introduce
themselves and so Richard can you please
tell us a little bit about yourself your
role in the company
sure my name is Richard Helms I work for
a company called sales loft salesloft is
a company that uh is basically a sales
engagement platform we also like to call
ourselves the revenue workflow platform
we use something called
we have a product called rhythm that
leverages Ai and we look at uh
people sales data and
their actions and Integrations with
their go to market integration products
and things like that to help their sales
people engage better
and make sales their sales process
better so me I work on the database
engineering team manage the database
Engineers my role is to keep our data
clean healthy
performant and uh
you know that's really my role in the in
the organization so
right
um Stacy please
uh yeah thanks Richard
um
so I work at Penn entertainment
we of course are an entertainment
company at the core
as you probably guessed
um
we
sorry
we operate the Barstool Sportsbook and
Pen Entertainment also owns and operates
43 brick and mortar casinos and race
tracks
um about two years ago pen entertainment
acquired a company called the score up
in Canada
which is where I reside in my Teamworks
and we develop and operate the score
media and the score bet and I mentioned
Barstool Sportsbook
and some of you may have heard already
that we've entered a partnership with
ESPN to operate their sports book as
well
um
my team is responsible for you know
planning and deploying all of the
infrastructure for cloud and on-prem
as well as the CI CD processes some
security aspects
and just generally you know keeping an
eye on like the performance and the
health of the backend services
so you're both Cloud SQL users Cloud SQL
for postgres if you can please talk a
bit about how you use it today and maybe
describe some details about the
deployment and we'll go maybe in the
same order so Richard please
sure we are a postgres only shop
as far as our development environments
we run postgres in containers on the
local developers laptops but from QA
forward
we run everything in Cloud SQL so our QA
environments we have probably
17 18 QA environments plus a couple of
sdet environments and then we have
multiple production regions each of our
regions are broken out into separate
Google projects
and each of those projects we have
uh what are called we've we've got
basically postgresql instances for each
microservice we've got at last count uh
I believe 48 microservices each backed
by a postgresql instance running on
cloud SQL various sizes depending on the
use case
and the applications themselves all run
in kubernetes either Elixir Ruby or go
is our application stack so
yeah so our deployment is a bit unique
and we have data residency requirements
so because we're in you know the betting
industry we have to abide by our US
federal law called The Wire act it
basically means that you can't send
betting data across state lines
so what this kind of means for us is
like the way we architected our
infrastructure is a hub and spoke model
of microservices so our core services
will run in you know gcp in the cloud
all in kubernetes and then we also have
all of our Edge services that facilitate
the Persistence of pet data
uh running at the edge and those are all
in postgres and kubernetes anthos
the postgres we all manage for on-prem
directly
this kind of model equates to about 450
postgres instances across all of our
microservices between about six non-prod
and obviously production environments
awesome
so obviously when you run and post this
instance in production data protection
is super important can you talk to us a
little bit about how you've implemented
data protection any lessons that you can
share with the audience here today based
on what you've learned doing that Stacy
maybe I'll start with you
sure so you know obviously because we're
running a cloud SQL we don't have to
worry too much about data protection
Google does most of that for us but in
terms of like the the backup and
Recovery scenarios we obviously run with
automated backups seven days of
retention we get the point in time
recovery that covers the delta
and then also for like Opera operational
protection
uh we run with delete protection on our
instances for you know anybody's flat
Fingers
um we also use automatic storage
increases that you know protects us from
that kind of embarrassing moments when
your disc fills up and you have an
outage
but obviously that can that can cause
like a runaway disc scenario but that's
obviously a reasonable trade-off to to
have
and then obviously
um I think everybody probably agrees
that
um running in multiple availability
zones is is also important so we we do
that too
and Richard
yeah I would say we use very similar
techniques uh probably the only thing
that I think that I would also add there
is that we do dual region backups
so I think that's probably important to
point out
in addition to that
we absolutely are super super careful
about making sure that we have deletion
protection on as well being a terraform
shop
the last thing we want to do is for
someone to do a rogue terraform destroy
and our database goes poof so you know
as far as Lessons Learned there you know
we've
certainly don't want something like that
to happen yes sure I think um one other
lesson I will share is that uh you know
we kind of talked about maintenance and
Google is pretty rigorous on doing their
updates and pushing them out
um you know it's it's really important
to be like really paying attention to
when those get scheduled and putting
your maintenance exclusions in so like
the Enterprise Plus is really promising
to see those 10 second maintenance
windows
thank you
so Richard your comments on terraform I
think we're a good segue to the next
question
um which is about terraform and you know
we uh you know as I was saying at the
beginning of the presentation
um you know we developer friendliness is
very important uh for cloud SQL and uh
infrastructure score or score is
something that we Embrace we have
support for terraform we have support to
KCC so maybe you can tell us Richard
maybe you can kick us off here uh how do
you use terraform today what are some
best practices you can share sure uh we
do use terraform as I mentioned before
we also um use a wrapper called Tara
Grant
as far as best practices I I could
probably share that best with a story so
um we're a pretty good hyper growth
example
um uh organization when I started with
the organization uh about four and a
half five years ago we were a pretty
small SRE shop with about three sres and
a single database engineer which was
myself and now we're about nine sres and
four database engineers
and we started with a single terraform
GitHub repo and a single state file and
um
that was a bad bad idea
and we have since learned that it's a a
good idea to really think about your
directory structure up front really
think about how many state files you
need to to have really think about
um you know if you're going to do things
like multiple regions and multiple
deploys in different regions
you know all of these things matter your
state files matter the probably one of
the bigger lessons we learned too was to
separate your modules from your actual
um
the development of your modules from
your actual the rest of your uh your
terraform resources themselves so those
are probably some of the the best
practices that that I could probably
share in that regard so
yeah I think the best one of the best
practices that I have is make sure that
you hook terraform up to some form of CI
and constantly keep running the plan I
have to make sure that it integrates
well
it's pretty terrible when you have to
open code that hasn't been touched in a
couple months and it is just drifted
entirely and the plan just completely
fails on you
um another kind of best practice I was
thinking about was you know when you're
developing terraform from kind of the
start
to kind of really think about you know
what kind of abstractions you're
building for your business
um you know where how do you group the
resources that you want and how do they
like which ones frequently are changing
um
maybe I'll give a bit of an example
um so we we try to build a module that
you know we could use to just spawn the
entire stock
um you know we it's a template and it's
backed by a few or like a handful of
smaller modules
um and this you know worked really great
for us once we got it running you know
it turned our whole stack deployment
from you know weeks and days down to you
know hours
but once people came in and started you
know tinkering with it and trying to
make changes it kind of fell apart
because the code complexity got really
high
um so you know I guess
to kind of pull back a little bit
um you know figure out where your
groupings are and and keep things
smaller and then figure out which layer
you want to glue those back together at
and otherwise you'll you'll run into
complexity issues
yeah some great I think best practices
there around you know hygiene and and I
think planning ahead uh with terraform
and I think both of you run sizable uh
you know fleets multiple instances
between you know different regions data
protection so for cloud SQL so in terms
of that how have you approached
observability throughout your deployment
and maybe Richard sure
um
you know we are a
um data dog and New Relic shop for
um a lot of our resources but in
addition to that
um you know especially around alerting
because we've we alert on so much in our
stack
um but once we've crossed like CPU
thresholds and things like that we do
start to fall back and start looking at
the query insights tools inside of the
cloud SQL product so once we've once
we've actually like alerted on something
that is pretty interesting to us we do
fall back on the query insights product
we use that to drill down and see what's
pretty much on fire we can identify
broken queries pretty quickly
and drill down and get to the root cause
of the problem pretty easily typically
you know a bad index or a query plan
that has changed over time for whatever
reason maybe some data you or something
like that we can see it pretty quickly
and get it addressed the other thing
about query insights that we really like
is we'll occasionally use the tool to
just rewind and go back in time and look
for trends that just look out of the
ordinary so and then we can be kind of
proactive and if we if we see things or
you know as I like to call them bumps in
the night that that just don't look
right in a particular environment we can
drill down and maybe get ahead of a
problem before it becomes a raging fire
in our environment so you know so we we
do certainly appreciate that
observability in the cloud SQL product
yeah so our organization also is
Consolidated our observability and
alerting into datadog so you know we use
the natural gcp integration that gets us
our high level cloud SQL metrics
we also have the logging which uses the
pub sub which is kind of an unfortunate
thing to have to deal with
[Music]
um
well we also use database monitoring
directly from datadog which gives us the
insights into postgres itself you know
the explained plans and the query
performance
we also actually still enable Cloud
insights on the gcp platform just as a
secondary layer if we do have some issue
with the instance we can contact Google
and they'll give us a little bit of help
if we need it
so yeah that's that's pretty our
observability platform is fairly
standard
yeah great to see you know use of query
insights as well as you know our
integration and partner tools that's
super awesome
so another question since we talked a
bit about PG Vector any chance that you
see opportunities or applications for
using PG Vector now that we have it
stay seal start with you yeah I think
keeping with the theme of the conference
with AI and mo uh I think the obvious
answer is yes
[Music]
with our with our products you know I
think because we're in sports media it
would be really cool to just you know
type into the app saying you know which
player has this stat and you know it'll
give you all the references back
um you know I think not having to shift
our data to yet another data store is
probably really awesome too I don't
think anybody likes having to shift data
around out of postgres if we all agree
that we like those graphs so yeah I
think it'll be really promising to see
what's coming down the pipe for for the
stuff
yeah I think in our
regard our data scientist team was
beating down my door the the day that uh
PG Vector
support was announced they they wanted
an instance and they wanted it now
so the opportunity is is definitely
there we've got product roadmaps that
already have PG Vector in in the works
in the plans uh there's there's probably
going to be something in our production
stack
probably in this quarter
so we're certainly already embracing
the
the opportunities that are in front of
us there so
super cool
so we talked a lot about maintenance and
you know I showed you the demo about the
near zero downtime maintenance and
Enterprise plus you know Cloud SQL gives
you a number of controls Stacy was
referring to one of them uh in terms of
you know either denying maintenance or
delaying maintenance depending on your
business requirements it's an important
topic and you know both of you run a
very large Fleet maybe Stacy you can
kick us off by talking about how you
think about maintenance for your
postgres instances and what are the
different controls that you use today
uh well maintenance windows with
postgres was not the most fun thing I
don't think if you had to survey the
room like how many people would actually
say they're running all the latest and
greatest postgres I wonder if there's
anybody still running less than 10
probably
um
so yeah I don't think maintenance is a
great experience right now but the
Enterprise policy I think it'll be
really good
um
yeah but like you said and I said
earlier you know we just use the
maintenance exclusions we really
scheduled make sure we're really
scheduling in those maintenance periods
because our app can't go offline and we
and because we're really regulated you
know we have to give our release notes
you know a week in advance before we can
actually push things out
foreign
so in in our case we'll
um we basically just set up
notifications and uh in the case where
our scheduling doesn't align with our
tolerated maintenance windows and
maintenance schedules we will go in and
use the gcloud API to put in a
maintenance exclusion and then
reschedule the the maintenance
but we will typically just allow them to
go if they align with our prescribed
maintenance windows
so for all of our instances we do have
you know we set a particular maintenance
window
and but occasionally there are
situations that for whatever reason
we're we're sensitive to per to specific
times of the month and times of the year
that are bad even though we have a
weekly
maintenance window
and so we'll adjust and whatnot so we we
just set notifications if the time's
wrong we'll override those notifications
with a with a with a deny period and
then we'll just remove the deny period
after
after the times passed and let it go in
the next window
and we've talked a lot about Enterprise
Plus and I know Stacy you mentioned they
are very excited about the near zero
downtime maintenance feature anything
else that that you find interesting in
Enterprise Plus itself and same question
for you Richard
I think uh you know just the general
performance increase will be really nice
to have you know we see some bottlenecks
already with you know going above 16
CPUs so I think it'll be really cool to
get a little bit more throughput out of
those instances
awesome
yeah I think a couple of things for us
the
definitely the addition and the the
more memory the the the addition of the
more the what is it eight
or excuse me eight gig yeah
the one to eight versus the one to six
point five so I think that's a big deal
for us
um and in addition to that uh the
the much much smaller maintenance
windows are going to be a huge win for
us
one minute's not a big deal but one
second is
certainly a it's it's huge it it means
that even in those less than desirable
Windows maybe they're more desirable now
so um
I think those are probably the two
things that I'm most excited about
it looks like we're coming up on time
here thank you so much for taking the
time to attend this session today
um you know thank you for being part of
the postgres community
um I I appreciate the fact that all of
you are as excited as us are for about
postgres there's a number of other Cloud
SQL sessions uh in the next couple of
days as well uh here's the list of
sessions do attend and give us your
feedback on them Jana and I will stay
behind to answer any questions that you
might have based on what you heard thank
you so much
thank you